So this lesson, showed the power, of the object technology, for
structuring complex application servers. EJB, allowed
developers to write business logic, without having to worry about
crosscutting, cancer such as security, logging,
persistence and so on. As a homework, what I would want you to do, is understand
the design choices that we discussed in
the lesson and analyze [UNKNOWN] the performance
implications, of those design choices, with respect
to concurrency, pooling of resources, number of object
classes, lines of code and so on. And read, the paper that I've assigned to you,
as part of the reading material for this course, in this topic, and relate
the arguments they present in the paper, against your own qualitative analysis.
A word of caution though, EJB has evolved, considerably, from the time
of this paper. But, the principals that are discussed in this paper,
apply, to the way complex entier applications are structured to this day.